so let's let's go back over to the title
tuesday tab here okay so there we go got
the standings back on your screen devil
shot 36 I didn't hit diamond no lost a
few too many games yesterday that it was
unrealistic so I didn't play today the
tournament is probably gonna start just
after the hour here so in about five or
six minutes there's about 170 people
here please adjust the board please
what do you mean the board looks fine to
me board looks fine to me I just have
the standings on top of it showing you
guys who's playing Magnus still in
tournament naca still here and this time
let's hope nothing goes nothing goes to
wrong Ireland yeah I was trying to hit
diamonds in League of Legends before the
season ended today and I just lost a few
too many games that I was even doing the
math and even if I won every game I I
wouldn't be able to hit it so I gave up
on that dream but almost almost
okay so it's starting very soon not as
many players as last time but there's
still lots of time to join I think most
of the same people are are playing and
we still have Magnus we still have the
kuru we still have MDL so I don't think
we lost any of the top guys which is
great of course for for us here watching
the viewership has noticeably decreased
since I started playing chess so I'm
definitely definitely not going to do
that again I promise you the rest of
this will just be will just be
commentary I will refrain from
displaying my ability to hang pieces any
longer but guys who aren't that good at
chess are usually really good at
explaining it that's what they say about
coaches right or teachers that's what
they said about teachers when I was in
school like oh yeah the teacher is the
person who was really good at the
subject but just not that good they
weren't good enough to have the best job
so they they started to teach it so
that's what I am in chess we're waiting
for the games to start think they'll
start in a couple minutes here hopefully
you guys still have energy hopefully you
guys are still here watching and you
know still have a couple hours
- two and a half hours in you to play
the tournament also I know a lot of
people who couldn't play the event
because of commitments now they actually
can play the event so I think there's
gonna be a few people who are actually
pretty happy in chat pretty happy thanks
chess calm for delaying the tournament
for an hour now I get a chance to maybe
play Magnus so guys like mannered monkey
can definitely be seated
so we're gonna we're gonna follow Magnus
on his first game hopefully things go
smoothly hopefully things go smoothly
we'll know right from the start you know
if we see e4 and we see a huge thing
then you can get suspicious but I think
things will be running smoothly
how you doing yodel Meister this is
Magnus versus Hikaru hype that's right
anyone can join as long as you have a
title that's all it is the master class
title Tuesday that's the only
requirement I guess the only
prerequisite gotta have a title
recognized by chess comm notice how I
include that last bit in because a lot
of people in chat are probably gonna say
they have their own title that they
created but it has to be recognized by
chess comm that's that's the most
important thing
who is Ana well I'm not sure I haven't
clicked the profile but I don't
necessarily know know who it is
almost all GM's in the top 10 and then
we got wonderful time 27 72 in fact I
think wonderful time that's a lower
rating I think some of the guys might
have been playing blitz in the meantime
while they were waiting for title
Tuesday to start I think there were some
blitz games going on I'd be curious to
know that okay I'm pretty sure the games
are gonna start like right now my thing
says it starts to seven minutes but I
think that that's that's delayed I think
that's from when when you click on it
and it doesn't update I almost click the
join button when I see Magnussen and car
in the tournament it's very tempting for
me to click join but I already promised
you guys no more chess only commentary
so starts in one minute starts in one
minute
don't forget NVL no I haven't forgotten
VL at all I've been mentioning his name
all stream so far
all right I think it's just about to get
started Danny Ranch in the chat giving
the official timestamps
what's the time regulation it's a 10
round tournament with three plus two
time control three minutes plus two
seconds increment per move Myer is in
the tournament yeah I saw Meyers new
Chandra is also in the tournament he's
right there
there's Meyer so this is just the top
ten of the tournament this isn't this
isn't the total tournament there's not
ten players in the tournament guys don't
worry okay there we go so now Magnus
Carlsen we're off to a start with no
issues he's playing a ruja I'm gonna
call him from Latvia and let me get that
thing out of the way first of all there
we go
get those standings out of the way so
you can actually see the chess before I
make you guys follow the entire game
blindfolded okay looks like a Philidor
Philidor defense and a four from Magnus
a5 immediately usually black goes for
ideas like c6 Queen c7 rookie a maybe h6
but these legs very important to take
those squares why it's gonna be playing
things like maybe h3 maybe Bishop e3
this Bishop has a choice usually in
these lines whether it comes back to f1
or a - but I like starting with h3 kind
of a more modest approach then you can
get your Bishop to e3 without dealing
with Knight g4 when black plays rook e8
sometimes 95 is is an issue just hitting
the the f7 square and then you can go
back to f8 Knight b6 is not a move I'm
used to I'm betting on Bishop f1
actually bye-bye Magnus here Bishop b3
he goes for us so yeah white decides
which diagonal he prefers bishop f1 is
more to play g3 Bishop g2 Bishop b3 just
kind of controls all the squares this
night might want to go to and keeps the
bishop on simply just one of the best
best diagonals in the position Bishop e3
takes takes
we probably see 95 here and we do 95 and
clean f3 so if the night takes white I
think is planning to take with the pawn
and then bring the rook to d1 we're
probably gonna see roof d1 here we do
and Magnus is is saying you know what go
ahead buddy take my bishop you you spend
a lot of time that night went from there
to there to there to taking on b3 spent
a lot of time just to get there and
after Knight takes b3 if pawn takes I
think he's saying that the D pawn is
gonna be weakness that's what he's gonna
be targeting meanwhile that night um b6
doesn't have any squares and after you
take don't forget that Bishop is looking
at that net on b6 and right now it's
undefended
so Queen to g3 targets the d6 pawn gets
ready for things like Bishop f4
attacking that square things like net f5
even Knight takes c6 is a potential idea
with these Knights starting to look a
little bit loose on the diagonal King h8
that seems extremely slow very very slow
I wouldn't be surprised if there was a
tactic here Bishop f4 he's going for
just simple pressure but the question is
how do you defend that pawn I mean are
we really playing rook b8
because rook e8 looks like it's kind of
overloading a few of these pieces Bishop
e5 Knight f3 I was gonna say you don't
want to take and let black take with the
pawn and then Knight f3 f6 for example
and black starts to say solid but you
want to play Knight f3 so that if you
wants to play move like f6 you take with
the knight and you actually get the dark
square control by keeping this Bishop
otherwise if black takes you you take
back and you're threatening to play e5
Magnus sees a tactic here and after
Knight takes b3 Knight takes e5 pawn
takes Bishop takes and there's a threat
of mate if f6 there's Bishop d6 and
don't forget white is always planning to
recapture the pawn on b3
magnus smurfing I don't think he's
smurfing that man she's 3037 rated I
think that is a very high rating rather
than a very low one don't think he's
smurfing what's he gonna play here it's
got a playoff six it's C on the move f6
Bishop d6 but then Y is just completely
winning you just take on a fait next so
this is I think this is just completely
lost okay rook there but you just take
and yeah black is down upon and while it
looks that like this Bishop might Bishop
c3 but also Bishop d6 and 94 yeah that's
what it's gonna be
smurfing if anyone knows any other games
like video games smurfing is when you
play on an account that is a lot lower
than your level but I don't think Magnus
is smurfing right now that 3037 seems
very representative of the kind of skill
we're seeing from this game right here
f5 he says go home Bishop back to c8 and
look at this night this is domination
that Knight cannot move to any of these
squares that it wants to then I don't b6
is simply the one of the worst pieces on
the board and white is white is for
choice with how he wants to close this
game out whether it's gonna be a 5 and
f6
I think Magnus is gonna go for an
approach that doesn't let this Knight
back into the game cuz ii 5 f6 is
committal and it lets the knight and
Bishop back into the game so I think
he's gonna try to lock those pieces out
and just play slow here maybe King H -
maybe Queen f4 he's 1 for Bishop c7 and
97 and then e 5 is that what he's going
for
it looks like it
now that the knight can't go to d5 what
we were just talking about and the
bishop is blocked by the night he goes
for a5 and to be honest you can even
take this here but it feels like leaving
the Queens on the board gives gives
better attacking chances he's even
preventing Knights e5
I mean this is really unfair
what we're watching here blacks night is
being put down look I mean he's going to
h7 the only square that's available the
night is finally getting into the game
but that Bishop is trapped now Magnus is
completely toying with him he's making
sure the guy cannot move a single one of
his pieces this is I mean this is over
this is over the bishop can finally move
but guys rope d8 is on the cards of
course we're gonna see Bishop takes h3
last-ditch effort but with that Bishop
covering the squares I'm sure Magnus
will be fine here I was gonna say Knight
h2 but even better 95 seems to force an
exchange here and I think he's just up a
piece so he can take and he always has
Queen g3 yep and rook T eights coming
next fall by b5 or queen up a
piece magnus carlsen is gonna play rook
d8 here and there it is rook d8 and how
does that feel if you're the guy from
the first title Tuesday you got your
game with Magnus and OOP sorry and then
this guy he gets thrown into the
gauntlet
he gets the Magnus pairing so it looks
like Magnus is going one and O in the
first round here let's take a look at
some of the other games and results
there's the wind for Magnus let's take a
look at em VL who's playing March and
some Sunday from Germany and to be
honest he might even be in trouble here
in big trouble I think black is
technically just winning here h3 is
hanging h3 is hanging
Black is down the exchange so there's
definitely lots of ways that white wins
this but g5 g4 is coming this just looks
really good for black I don't see the
rooks coordinating very well the only
thing is time and how tricky MVL can be
one thing watch out for his rook b2 in
clean c2 that's what he's going for he
wants to trade the queen's nighty one
clever check and he's got a block with
the rook Knight f3 was was coming and
that was gonna be lights out I thought
he might just why didn't he take that
guy's and play Bishop d2 okay I mean
it's definitely still winning but taking
a Bishop d2 did look like a pretty nice
one now she doesn't take that pawn as
well so interesting technique by some
sunny but nvl guys looks like he is
going down it looks like he's going to
lose this position there's Queen f3 on
the cards but the nice thing for him is
he's got checks he's got some checks
coming he can take this well why didn't
he take that what on earth why didn't he
take that guys takes g3 Queen age 3
check I mean black has really really
botched this position oh this is very
bad
he's going for a draw now and they'll
probably doesn't want to take it but I
think he has to he's even too bad of a
spot here to not take the draw Wow Wow
so many so many things to to think about
here first of all if he takes that I
think the idea was check but there's
always g6 and Bishop block like you're
not getting into any trouble err so I
think he can just take that pawn the
other thing that might have been easier
is you always got to consider you know
whether trading the Queen's just makes
your life in the endgame that much
easier black rolls his King to f5 plays
g5 g 4 takes this pawn I think that's a
think that's a walk walk in the park so
my opinion huge
chance missed by black there the German
I am and MVL escapes by the skin of his
teeth in round one already some tough
tough pairings let's take a look at
wonderful time
who's playing an angry Serb he's playing
an angry Serb and would not be surprised
if this was winning for white actually I
think I think it should be
a for the the site goats by the top
players as nvl escapes that happens time
and time again entitled Tuesday and
believe me I know because I I've been
psyched out by by the top players before
but there's something psychological
there that it's really hard to put those
guys away you already feel like a draws
a good result but man that was a huge
huge opportunity missed in my opinion so
in this one black is sting pretty firm
here with this blockade it's kind of
interesting I didn't think it would be
that effective but if the King goes up
here then I think he's got that check
which is the idea he you want to go over
there you go now is this something I got
excited there but after rook f7 I'm
sorry not rook f7 just just king there
again if you move the King up I think he
always gives the check and that's it so
how do you make progress here this is
actually interesting how do you make
progress you want to ideally bring your
king up here so why doesn't he go here
like king g3 and King there and then to
deal with that check just make sure your
queen isn't on the h-file that's what
I'm thinking
well it was black going for the win now
you gotta be a little careful there f5
is coming I think black got a little
ahead of himself with that one now the
King gets up to G for King g4 yeah no
black got a bit ambitious in my opinion
so check probably check and then does
King their wind that's the question does
King here win like I mean how's this
endgame
looks like it black is just in time with
with that so he's keeping the Queen for
now but how do we how do we crack this
position this is one of the last games
going in the round
Magnus already won his game we already
covered that one what's gonna happen
here king g5 there's always there's yeah
there's always rook f5 ok well getting
rid of that pond over there really
reduces the chances that white has of
winning this in my opinion I don't like
to move a 5 at all
we're only in round 1 of the title
Tuesday because we restarted the
tournament King f3 I I don't think
progress is being made here look at 5 or
Bishop f5 but yeah I don't see what I
can do here anymore
you can try King D 4 but where where are
you going really ok Queen h4 now king e5
you can try it
a5 I didn't think black had to do
anything I thought his position was I
thought his position was pre compact
like he was kind of holding everything
together
a4 well that pawn is running queenie 5
how do you make progress here though
this is too solid now in my opinion just
a3 keep going yeah
now White's gonna have to go deal with
that pawn and then I think it's okay a 2
right now is a nice trap a to take and
then what just rook takes that for Queen
age - so what's happening here
that's a blunder he missed rook F for
Queen h2
guys there was Queen age too to win the
rook is this position winning once again
we have the dilemma what a long game I'm
sure this is the last game of the round
is there a way to take the rook and
Bishop and win the King and pawn endgame
that's what I want to know I think
that's the best chance here I'm King g8
he wants Queen h6 that's very powerful
very powerful yes angry Serb has
declined to draw so now if rook a five I
don't think it can be taken because
black draws that King and pawn endgame
gotta watch out for Rocky eight I think
that white is very close to to tricking
black here in this endgame Queen III wow
this is going the distance I wonder
rook air-five always on the cards and
that king of d7 just doesn't see me
making any progress
I'm trying to construct a winning idea I
don't see one it's very hard to do only
four seconds for white by the way
dubious chess is calling that wife like
whoa what is rook h8 what is rook h8
wait a minute what whoa was that
necessary
just rook f5 what on earth is he doing
rook a shade is like the worst moving
the entire position well now this is
lost
rook h8 is the absolute worst chess move
that you could play there apart from
just giving up your rope I'm sure this
must be lost now just f6 f6 right King
f6 no this is game over guys that is so
bad what is that I can't believe like
when you have a fortress and you've been
shuffling for probably 40 45 50 moves
what makes you make a move that you've
never made for the last 50 moves right
like what you've been making 45 moves
and your opponent has made no progress
uh yeah you know what let me try
something different oh man
that is really bad that's a victory for
angry serve that is an upset and we're
on to the next round Magnus Carlsen with
the black pieces here playing the nihms
oh they're very puzzling mistake indeed
x-prime
I don't know I can't explain it but
we're on to the next game a 2560 FM
playing against Magnus - is gone for
Bishop a6 a bit of a positional concept
trying to get rid of the LightSquared
bishop and the bishop on c1 then becomes
an issue bishop on c1 is gonna be a
tough piece so it's you're gonna take
and play c5 I think that might be what
he does a3 is a very friendly move I
mean black wants to take that night
anyway he just encourages it 94 if
Bishop to b2 we might even see the move
96 is that an option no it's gonna be
take take c4
I think c4 could have been played there
with Queen a4 and taking the pawn back
if queen c8 we are definitely seeing c4
actually I think we're seeing c4 no
matter what the what move black plays we
can even switch the board let's take a
look at what Magnus is looking at but
you've got to play this move or this
move that's it he's going back we're
gonna see c-4 knight c6 yeah he wants to
put the night there take back place c5
bring the rooks whoa that's not what I
meant to click Knight a5 of course takes
takes and then black wants to play c5 so
it looks like a nice positional game so
far for black trying to play on the
light squares play against the fact that
white doesn't have the light squared
bishop white really needs to get f3 knee
for it if he doesn't do that I think
he's in big trouble
so c5 yep there it is what's the
tournament called Chuckie it is the
master class title Tuesday November
edition here and we had a few technical
issues earlier on so that's why it's
starting a little bit later today
see five no this is this is a problem
for white this is a problem I'm gonna
take a look at nakos game because we
haven't taken a look yet at what he's
doing I think he's gone for his coveted
b3 Bishop b2 and he has I think he's
happy with this position and real boy
from used Becky Stan I wonder if that's
I wonder if that's the recent recent GM
pretty sure that that guy is also from
use Becca stone Knight takes g4 and it
looks like there's made on f2 made on f2
not mate but very close to me he wants
to wants to take on f2 and try to
smothered mate Nakamura and I think his
chance of doing that is fairly low
family honest here are we gonna see
efore and probably bring the Queen back
and put the night on b6 no he is taking
pawns we have a greedy Guillermo in the
building that's a hanging bishop and if
Bishop g5 yeah I think he is gonna play
at four why not that that's just a basic
fork why not
okay let's get back to the Magnus game
but naca looking good there a bit dicey
positions a little bit dicey but it is
looking good and Magnus is doing pretty
much what we expected
c5 rook e8 you just bring the rooks to
the center and if white can get F 3e4
has very good chances but that is a hard
ask at the moment
Queen b3 the entire game Magnus has just
been playing against this Bishop on b2
and now he's actually offering Queen
take z4 meaning takes b2 and what
happens if Queen f5 I guess he's playing
f6 so that's what happened Queenie for
Queen there while I'm a little surprised
by that I am a little surprised by that
because the whole game he was playing as
the bishop on b2 now it's definitely
still a good end game for black because
we have these three pawns over here so
always have the Queen side majority but
what happens after f6 here I'm sure
that's the move maybe Knight c4 yeah
probably 9 c4 Knight see 493 actually
also looks really good but Knight d3
maybe we can take that pawn and we have
pressure on the night knight Knight
takes rook takes and then there's
pressure on on c5 as well but Magnus is
just gonna take that pawn yeah he would
have just taken that pawn if if either
of these name is so white decides to
just go back but this pawn covers all
the knight moves and yes and Magnus is
saying you know what
thanks for the pawn oh thanks for that
pawn as well I'll take that he's
probably gonna move the Queen again like
Queen c3 or queen bee - oh nasty rook da
now it's just Clinic now all he has to
do is save the Queen and how many pawns
City just clean up their two pawns for
free
efore probably gonna be played yeah and
Magnus has everything under control now
the knight can come to d4 or d2 the
Queen can come back on this diagonal and
there's just no threats against the King
and there you go he just cleaned up two
pawns all he has to do is trade Queens
and it's pretty easy to say that any end
game is completely winning
for for Magnus here so Queen only five
would be nice that's what he's
immediately threatening and Kay his
opponent doesn't see it so that's just
game over we don't have to look at the
rest of this endgame Magnus is gonna put
this one away but let's go back to akaru
who right now is down a queen we have to
take a look at this real boy is coming
for the naca scalp it is rook Knight and
Bishop against Queen very imbalance game
let's take a look at it it's gotta be
Knight takes e5 here
no not Knight takes e5 what's wrong with
Knight takes e5 what happens this rooks
just coming here real boy he's trying
he's gone in a balance position you
can't ask for much more that cos King is
still sort of out there on c3 doesn't
have a lot of cover Brooke f1 played is
he gonna take that I think he almost has
to okay this is a very fun position
everything in White's position is
defended though that's the only thing if
King there he wants to give a check
again oh he just missed that now could
just hung his knight knack tomorrow just
hung his night guys
he is gonna be playing with a fury now
as he needs to make this pawn count oh
man that is very bad are we gonna see
his pawns push yes aged five white
cannot moved upon nafta morrow just hung
his knight and real boy looks like he's
gonna come with a nakamura scalp rook f7
he thought that black was gonna play
King h7 Nakamura going down in round two
that is a massive upset he expected king
h7 and free move rook f7
oh no that is bad news for our Nakamura
everything is defended in five seconds
later naka hangs his night yes that's
unfortunately what just happened I don't
think there was a way out of it for
Nakamura now that I'm thinking back in
the position because it's not like he
hung his night it's like the movie night
a 408
so technically here Knight takes a four
after check no matter where you put the
king queen d1 picks up the night so
that's why it wasn't like you know his
move was just a huge blunder that
blundered the night it was more than
night a for he missed Queen c1 and then
then the night was lost anyway so that's
that's a big blow early for Hikaru
Nakamura Magnus is on to a tattoo let's
take a look at some of the other games
still going Egor Kovalenko here with the
white pieces it looks like he's holding
the e pawn yeah and if you hold the e
pawn here with white then you should be
winning also it helps that he's up about
20 seconds here as well
see seven night there yeah
and we're just gonna see the pawn march
up the board I think c4 yep
Mic Check and I would just run these
kingside pawns another win here for
Kovalenko with the white pieces let's
take a look at some of the other games
this is an interesting one does white
have any winning chances I would say no
I would say no but rook against Knight
and pawn I think this one is just gonna
be a draw yeah I don't mean there's any
progress to be made
if white wants to make progress he's got
to bring his King all the way around a
king d3 King c4 King diva oh oh man oh
guys I can't look at that one that is
tough to look at a full rook hang by
Alexander fear from Brazil a very very
accomplished GM and blitz ooh that I
mean that's just lights out game over I
was just saying that if white wants to
do anything
yes it's bringing the King around but
you know you don't do it when the
Knights not paying Knights e5 with a
minute and 20 on the clock oh man look
at the blunders that we are seeing look
at the blunders guys that is another
very big result oh we're almost seeing
rook and Bishop against rook but there's
a pawn on the board so I think lonesome
George here should be able to take the
win just March that pawn up the board
rook can go over on a2
he wants to play probably bishop there I
don't he wants to just play Butchie one
nice one lonesome George I like that
username lonesome George the peoples
champ and we got Don cappuccino against
the Canadian friend of mine Gary Inge oh
did he just make a mistake no he's got a
night at five at the end Knight f5
there we go that Canadian technique that
Canadian technique there we go
I think that's it I think that's it for
the round
all right it's round three out of ten
now we got
[Music]
wait where's Magnus doesn't Magnus have
to attitude
I see MVL has withdrawn after his after
his draw but where's Magnus isn't him
for some reason I don't see it unless
they're putting him way at the bottom of
the two attitudes yes yes Magnus
apparently has the worst high brakes on
to edit - I was wondering where his name
was that doesn't make any sense
he was hiding yeah magnus carlsen with
some of the worst tiebreaks so far in
the tournament he's 3039
and he's got the white pieces against
Rexel another feed a master
soon we're gonna see the GM on GM
matchups the hyped ones the ones you all
signed up to see but we might see g4
from Magnus here depends oh he wants to
handle the position with g4 or just
Queen e2 bishop there but g4 is
definitely very tempting he's going with
93 again just another positional game by
Magnus Carlsen I'm a big fan boy just
watching and learning
thanks Aquila thanks for that comment Oh
Ben Ben I think we all want to see GM on
GM action there's nothing like there's
nothing like that Knight f5 and c3
now I don't think this is particularly -
to open up the position like that but he
just doesn't want to see the knight end
up on d4 this one is always annoying if
you have to take with the pawn but g4 is
still consideration I don't think blacks
launching a very scary attack anytime
soon
before before now is looking a little
more tempting that he's he's given up
the initiative over there I like b4 b4
with bishop takes a 7 and then Bishop
back to b6
I would like to do that ooh Knight h6
that's not that's not something you
usually want to allow I'm waiting for
magnets to play d4 I hope I'm correct
about that but I think before is a good
move
a good way to pry open the position Wow
especially if we get to take the
LightSquared bishop like that this is
normally very good whoa hang on a sec
what what do you keep like Queens before
I'm really a fan of this before but I
guess I'm just misguided here I think he
wants to do it but he's just finding the
perfect perfect way to execute it you
might want to get this rook involved
first still there's no no way that
bishop can escape there is no way you
can move it because the knight would be
hanging so that bishop losing
LightSquared bishop here white can
always play them
be five and get a really nice end game
but black blacks position is kind of
crumbling here must be a six or Bishop a
seven there we go nice to see the b4
move I wasn't totally wrong I think we
might see b6 here I just can't think of
a nicer move b5 obviously loses two
pawns taking looks suicidal letting
white taken b7 looks crazy so I mean
yeah it's gotta be it's gotta be b6 here
whoa that's not a move yeah b6 let's
play Queen takes we're gonna see Queen
c7 here I think and White's attacking
the knight meanwhile if Queen d7 Queen
to a eight forces Bishop there and then
after pawn takes there's just ropes
coming to c1 everywhere I think he's
gonna snap this night off pretty quickly
yeah I would do that and now you can
choose your check or you can just take
this and bring the rope to c1 next you
might have to be a little careful how
you do this but Magus up more than a
minute on the clock more than a minute
here what's gonna happen to Queen e6
doesn't look good enough he's gonna
start with rook c1 and what now Queen b3
yeah black wants to try to leave this
Bishop on c5 I think and prevent white
from playing d4 and just say that he's
solid with the Bishop on c5 meanwhile
white might try to bring the Knight to
f5 is it gonna be Bishop F or sorry
Bishop c5 yes it is doubling king over
it's tempting to take this twice because
of mate but I I'm not sure if it really
works after Queen d7 at the end
Magnus thinks it does Queen d7 and then
what
or Queen b6 I should say hmm okay I
guess I guess this is a tough position
to play for black for sure but
something-something did seem a bit off
about above the position I thought Queen
d7 might have been a better move to
watch over d5 but Magnus shows some good
foresight here because you can't move
the rope because of Queen d5 check in
every position basically rook can't move
anywhere can't move up because of rook
c8 no this is just this is just a really
hard position to play for black you can
barely put the pieces anywhere rook c7
probably threatening Queen c6 yeah gotta
move the Queen back now or go there and
I think there might even be very close
to to a win here for white I don't quite
see it yet I was thinking something like
this and Queen c5 but I don't think
there's a win in the position just yet
rook takes a6 is not a threat because of
Queen d5 so Magnus might move his knight
here you might get the knight into the
game night here or night there the other
alternative is Queen c5 which I thought
that he might have played okay know if
you can't take that pawn I guess this is
this is pretty bad I guess you can just
take and take with the night and then
rook takes a6 what are we doing Knight
takes rook takes a6 is one of my ideas
the rook covers that now and if you take
I take here so he starts with rook to b7
Queen c8 and now Queen b5
can I take this he does I think I think
that was missed by by Magnus rook takes
a 6 no this is not clear this is not
clear anymore I still believe that
Magnus is gonna win this position but
it's definitely fair to say that that
rook takes a6 move was missed because
that that was a resource that was
mentioning for a while and finally black
did find a way
to get it to work but Magnus is just
gonna clean up pretty much every pawn
the guy has to his name and I don't
think black can survive here especially
with ten seconds left to a minute yeah
rook d5 and we're gonna see e5 still
Magnus is probably gonna pull away with
this position yeah II five this pawn is
loose rook before it seems maybe Queen
d2 d3 he wants Rokia has a threat
Queenie four yeah and there's the pin
there so there's no more rook before
whoa
no more rope before II 6 broke there
that's gonna be a pawn with check if you
wanted to take that plus knight c6 I
think this is very close to just
completely losing rook d7 Queen c5 and
where's the finish just east 7 e7 looks
very good okay takes the pawn first and
if he wants he can go back and play you
7 yeah he's gonna do that a fun game by
Magnus sacrifices and everything King
over and where's the nice finish
rook d8 right Queen c7 g3 I'm sorry
Queen sevens illegal Queen c7 he's not a
move to play there we go
and that'll be came over I think he's
gonna resign there he doesn't resign I
can't blame them you know you're playing
Magnus gotta got a play on but this just
three pawns Plus now obviously 96 is
coming so nice nice game by Magnus guys
that was a pleasure to watch he
sacrificed he gave the fans what they
want watching big fish 1995 what's the
evaluation of this end game it looks
completely winning if black takes the
rook so I think you have to play broke
there yeah and big fish looks like he's
gonna put an end to this game maybe c5
to give yourself a past a pawn I think
that's definitely possible
see Pfeiffer passed a pawn doesn't look
like a bad idea I think I would
definitely consider that but rook takes
is a threat so God to do c5 now right
a5 well the reason I wanted to do c5 is
because I I think it's always better to
have passed pawns that are not near one
another so further apart they are the
better rook at five followed by c5 but I
think this is gonna be a textbook win by
big fish in 1995 here there we go
he won by resignation of course as he
just won his opponent's Bishop that'll
be enough to get him to resign let's
take a look at Dmitri Andre Kim and
we're not gonna have to look for very
long because this looks over King takes
h3 and it's rook and Bishop plus pawn
against rook we've seen that too many
times
Bishop f3 or rogue h2 of course is just
me so there we go Andre Kim comes away
with a victory and let's take a look at
Bilodeau a who I believe is curial Alex
anko rookie 7 all these pawns on dark
squares which means that well if the
King moves of course there's always King
b6 you just can't give up that square
what's he gonna do about rook d7 I was
just gonna say you have to take probably
and now pushing the pawn but white can
always cover it with the night and the
rook and then you can just bring your
King over and take the pawn
look I have seven I think actually like
what I was expecting was he would bring
the rook back like that so I think he's
gonna play rook c2 here
rook see - probably right
ooh whoa oh he wants to does he want to
meet him here somehow King there there's
gotta be rugby to check King here but
then there's H - I mean Black's almost
winning here King there no black blacks
like gonna win this game maybe you got
to be really careful here with white
rook takes h2 rook e1 he's gonna go this
way I don't like like getting the King
out though that doesn't make much sense
to me
there's always check she's always check
who he box the King out there that was
pretty important black wants this last
pot but now I'm not sure that he gets it
because of 94 and there might even be
some ideas like Brooke f8 check okay
King back to f5 no rook h4 g5 can be
taken probably King III no now the king
goes to f5 this is not probably not
right I think they might do a repetition
here to be honest this looks scary for
white black is the one who wants to play
94 I'm not sure because King III King e5
and I'm not sure that black is is
getting that much here ya know now take
this and white just wins
Brooksie to rook c2 seemed a bit easier
but rook d2 and black got optimistic
guys he's the high rated player is 2,800
he saw his opponent might get into
trouble there thought he was gonna go
for a win when he's down a piece but now
he's just completely losing blunders
blunders
okay let's see if White has the
technique for this
Magnus finishes his game and he just
sits there and waits for everyone else
to to catch up he's had very easy games
so far it's been playing well shredder
Sherlock I am NOT playing this title
Tuesday no as a commentator I am
definitely not playing what on earth is
white doing with his night can anyone
explain that to me can anyone explain
this night to me what on earth is that
guy doing I just can't explain it
finally get back into the game buddy
Knight b7 what are you doing I don't
think it's necessarily obvious John that
that magnus is playing well he was
pretty critical of himself in his last
speech chess championship for not
playing that well but entitled Tuesday's
he really handles his opponents very
efficiently we saw upsets we saw natka
lose a game we saw nvl draw a game that
he was dead lost in so you see what I
mean when I say he's playing well it's
like you know other guys who are top
players in the world they do give up
draws and losses but Magnus seems to be
in good form this should be over Brooke
f6 is a nice move maybe or maybe it's
not a nice move because rook a 6 then
you play king h4 and you want to play g4
g5 I think that's how you do it here
yeah well King h4 I would put the king
on h4
I think the King probably needed to be
on h4 I don't know what this is is he
just gonna run the King around now maybe
ok the knight on e6 defends the pollen
pollen defense rook rook defends tonight
look at that cute little pattern gotta
move the rook now just bring the rope
down there you go and you can bring the
King in very nice King to f6 next and
you'll be able to check the black King
away with the rook in the night somehow
I wonder how he's gonna do this one
check King their rope there at this
point there's a lot of things that that
do win okay he finally took the pawn I
think this is the last game when we
double check yep this is the last game
so we'll stick with this but White's
just why is just Queen his pawn here
King e8 working there there we go so
over pushing guys we saw 2800 player
very good GM think that he might be able
to beat his lower rated opponent down
piece bad idea bad idea and he pays for
it with his L oh he loses this one just
make a queen there's no stale matrix
just rook takes and mate in one big
upset there as well as we move into
round 4 Magnus
still perfect three out of three and so
are a lot of other people there are
definitely gonna be some big matches
this time but nothing nothing like what
we just saw
so speaking of what we just saw Magnus
there we go
Chrisann 94 the guy who just upset his
opponent and oh let's let's follow
Magnus's Bishop f4 isn't it nice to see
the Bishop f4 come up Magnus championing
this opening getting a lot of people to
convert including myself to the London
system g4 Bishop e6 knight Knight g5 so
97 I'm a bit unsure about it it's gotta
be Bishop before here I think it's the
only move before g5 takes takes
takes takes and we have the Queen
hanging so I think Bishop before was was
working maybe but then you run into
things like 92 and f3 traps of Bishop I
have a feeling Bishop e4 probably could
have been played there but I mean this
is just disgusting this is nasty
yeah 97 we can always take usually what
you want to do is take this and then
play the move f4 so black can't play e5
but this does not look good
this does not look like a good position
maybe Bishop d3 you don't want to take
on c7 and take on e6 because g5 happens
but instead he plays f4 he wants to just
trap the bishop running that F pawn up
the board f5 in response now is probably
the moment where you grab that Bishop I
would imagine interesting that he plays
this way if I was black I wouldn't be
that upset with this to be honest
this doesn't look bad scary running the
HP up the board I would have played b5
maybe if I was black there c3 of course
94 taken immediately in ID to this
bishop is not gonna be very good piece
though pretty much for the whole game
here what if you take and play b5 I
think that's what should be played or
now you don't have to play it because
the palms are hanging but in my opinion
Magnus is gonna have a hard time
actually winning this position but we
will see blacks doing I would say a
little bit better than most of the other
attempts we've seen against Magnus so
far so this one's gonna be tough
Hikaru was at two out of three he did
lose the second round in an upset a big
upset so he's got some work to do to
catch up but Dan is a he is only just
behind Magnus so he's chasing he's
giving chase let's take a look at what
Magnus is gonna do in this game because
he has a very bad bishop here Bishop on
e1 is not good how is he gonna make it
work because normally if Magnus is
playing black I would probably say
Black's gonna win but because he's
playing white and wondering where the
magic is gonna happen where is the
Magnus magic gonna happen why do some
people play Knight f3 before Bishop f4
in the London system that's the tough
question answered the long story short
is it doesn't really matter you can
interchange those moves if you want is
there any way we can check the
tournament standings I will show the
tournament standings probably after the
next round just once we get things a
little more clarified but there's 170
people right now and still quite a few
people leading with three out of three
so we'll wait until it gets a bit more
defined and then I will put them on the
screen here C takes d4 and after C takes
there's there's some issues aren't there
with this pawn I mean you just lose upon
I mean when I say issues I'm talking
real issues like you just lost upon like
what what on earth is going on here I I
would have played them with b5 probably
in this position to strengthen the the
pawn on c4 but he kind of just
nonchalantly made some moves and all of
a sudden it's like wait he just lost
upon that's a little surprising this
Bishop is a non-factor Magnus is just in
his element he's playing fast he's
getting endgames and he's beating pretty
much everyone in the end games here
after Knight takes so after Knight takes
pawn takes rook takes what is white
planning to do okay he's gonna take that
and there's no check thanks to the
bishop and that bishop is almost trapped
Bishop c5 is very close to winning the
bishop so Bishop c5 yeah wins a piece
Bishop h8 just take that pawn so we'll
probably see him resigned here honestly
Magnus disposes of a guy who just had a
huge upset and after king e2 I mean he's
just gonna resign here both pieces are
hanging Wow look at that he really makes
it look easy sometimes okay seven he's
gonna take that pawn he could give a
check on e7 yeah he's gonna do that just
so there isn't any rock h2 but I don't
know why blacks playing on right here I
definitely wouldn't doesn't feel right
not against the world champion you're
down a piece let's take a look at Hikaru
and whoa this one looks fun okay so this
was the opening and it already got
really exciting early on just playing
through a quickly Bishop c4 I mean look
at this position Kanaka
is going for the kill here he's gonna
take back and what happens down here if
there's either a mate or black is is
totally fine it's gotta be Queen f7 so
you only move a four is on the cards is
king b1 the move rook there does that
work King takes and rook g1 yes nice one
from Nakamura very very nice combination
there ooh that needs a replay we only
just arrived
but the fireworks were just starting
rook e1 Queen f7 and rook g8 of course
if black doesn't play Queen f7 there's
made on g7 so I think that's just just a
very nice combination
nice stuff well calculated from Nakamura
he moves to three out of four okay let's
bring up the game between two GM's
Conrad Holt
playing black haired wretch and very did
not say who is Grand Master Gawain Jones
and this just looks like the pawns are
rolling I mean why does the two bishops
but something like that
really doesn't make an effect in a
position like this there's only eight
seconds left for for white here yeah and
you just see the pawn rolling there's a
knight a four yeah there's nothing here
Knight a four and rook c1 this bishop is
not playing rook c1 yeah that's it
that's definitely an upset big upset
based on ratings as Gawain Jones goes
down to Conrad Holt so definitely a
tournament full of upsets so far and
probably in the next two rounds we are
really going to see the big marquee
matchups take place looks a look at the
top game in progress
and let's stop looking at the top game
in progress because already we saw big
fish 1995 take the victory with the
black pieces over incognito night so
what's the what's
game to follow here every game I've
clicked on his ended as soon as I've
clicked it how about we take a look at
Oh what what am i a magician or
something I click a game and it ends I
was gonna say let's take a look at Bobby
s against narratives keep it narrow disc
II just closed it out okay well why
don't you guys pick a game that you want
me to end and I'll click on it and we'll
know result
how about hmm how about your admirer
let's find out his result click his game
oh that's all that's odd the game didn't
end it should end when I click it huh
well actually the position is completely
reasonable for white so Rodney Trotter
is is just not very cooperative here
because I think that white can resign
this position and not feel too
embarrassed rook takes e3 very nice move
and Bishop d6 gain over your clarinet
very nice conversion there okay there we
go
so I pretty much solved it king a6
that's this is some deep stuff yeah if
you don't resign you deserve to get
punished I hope he makes twenty Queens
alright he's gonna give him me yeah no
need to waste time here that game is
over let's take a look at Anna well here
it looks like he's losing to Terry
Renato takes b4 b5 yeah if you take
there's rook f5 and you get a pawn back
yeah that's just over unfortunately
because these ponds are too strong
together and this rook can always come
back to g1 so before here
sorry b5 III maybe b6 and just bring the
rook back there and just sacrifice on a
one a seven King B five and a seven King
a six and that's it
I know well looks like he's going down
another upset Renaud Oteri Luhan I've
played an entitled Tuesday before and I
also lost I find him a very very tough
opponent only and I am from Peru but I
believe his feed a blitz rating is also
extremely high so he's definitely a very
good very strong blitz player remedy HS
that's not a dumb question at all there
are definitely prizes for for this
tournament all these these players are
competing for cash prizes I would like
to think that there's a world where
Magnus Carlsen just shows up and plays a
fun blitz tournament you know just for
the sake of it but the reality is that
that's not gonna happen you put some
money on the line that's how you get the
the big guys out to play so that's
that's not a silly question at all this
this tournament is sponsored by
masterclass so that's that's where your
prizes come from and we're waiting here
for g5 there it is finally G v h6 this
should be winning for white h6 bring
your king to h5 and that should be it I
think the easiest way to do this is King
g4 oh I guess that's an even easier way
I was thinking king g4 night there and
king h5 but this is much much simpler
and just g6 g7 and there you go
yeah dubious chess I agree you know it's
not like first place in this tournament
is gonna make or break Magnus's taxes at
the end of the year but having a bit of
money on the line does get everyone a
little competitive and definite out the
best in people
it always feels nice to to see that
you're competing for something so I mean
it brings out that the best players in
the world so clearly something being
done right next round round five I'm
just gonna bring up the standings so
that everyone can see them as it is
starting to get clarified we have only
eight people with four out of four and
of course Magnus Carlsen there is one of
them and Toby Wan kenobe ironically the
guy who was paired against Magnus in
round one of the last title Tuesday
earlier today that got cancelled there
he is 4 out of 4 so we might see a
rematch chasing is a carbon a chimera at
3 points we see at the bottom of your
screen there Vladimirovich aka Jimmy
John Drake in three and a half out of
four and number one in the tournament
right now is blitz stream blitz stream
saying hello with four out of four let's
go into the games I wonder who is
playing who Magnus Carlsen playing
Manuel Petrosian there we go and this is
a pretty topical line right now
very very topical Magnus is not going
for b6 but going for d5 Queen's Gambit
and Bishop before for those that don't
know he played this against alexei dray
of in the World Cup and he won a very
nice game with black okay things are
getting spicy already
Petrosian from Armenia against Magnus
Carlsen from Norway Bishop takes f6
Queen takes f6 Queen d4 he's got to be
just exchanging here yeah he does might
see f3 but how can black be upset he's
got this very very powerful dark-squared
bishop I think this is just
I think this is just black going to give
a clinic here on the dark squares you
just can't play these positions normally
with this structure and not have a dark
square bishop these pawns are going to
be double that wouldn't be surprised if
if black considers moves like Bishop c5
Bishop e6 or even Bishop d6 and just
give up that pawn and play the position
with with the pieces so Magnus
definitely looks very comfortable here
naca has actually been giving some nice
comebacks dr. Bassam is the guy that I
want to focus on right now because for
those that don't know he's the first the
first player from from Africa to reach
20 700 club so dr. person that's not
just a funny way of calling himself he
really is a doctor he really is a
medical doctor and he bounces that with
being in 2700 he just hit 2,700 I think
that's a really huge achievement for him
but also something we have to mention
just because he's a really nice guy met
him in person and very impressive to to
balance a serious medical career as well
as maintaining 2700 level rating in
chess which is just very impressive
overall so something there that's that's
nice to note he's here with three points
and he's playing Bilodeau a who just
lost that that big game the upset game
just a couple rounds ago so he's bounced
back both were is that three points
right now at a four definitely gonna be
chasing Magnus Carlsen let's see what
other games we have going on here as we
take a look at the list let's see let's
see
- Magnus has been providing some
entertainment but really Hikaru has been
playing the most interesting games I
think his games have always been really
big attacks so here after Bishop takes a
three I think he just dropped upon all
of a sudden
he turns it around with Bishop D 497 and
here just just a tactic rook takes d7
what a shot by Hikaru rook takes d7 and
you might think well there's no way can
be a good move because it's covered by
the knight but then you see the Queen h7
Queen h8 tactic this is why I wanted to
get to the knack of game guys because he
really has been providing the craziest
games of the tournament so far and the
most fun wants to watch if h h4 h5 it's
going to stop tonight from winning g6
rook a to though is a threat right now
white wants to meet that with Bishop d3
and notice how NACA just rerouted his
Bishop to cover the f2 pawn so he's not
gonna have any trouble here yes Magnus
is 4 out of 4 right now probably h4 this
is usually the kind of move you want to
throw in we might see Queen g4 as well
h5 and I think you can take this to be
honest although he will necessarily want
to do that rook c8 here and then 94 he
took that pretty quickly but I think
white is just completely winning here 97
probably the only try but just Knight
takes c6 covers the pawn that pawn is
covered as well and after Knight a7 I
think it's just over c6 and I takes b5
yeah that's gonna be it
ok he takes with with the Brooke and
after Bishop takes Knight takes White's
gonna move the bishop and there's
definitely still conversion phase 2 to
go through but technically speaking I
think I think this one is should be
should be over let's just examine this
long this line which is what he's
calculus calculating right now something
like this and then if the pawn pushes
more I imagine we could do something
like this in the 94 or Knight a 4 is
what he's looking at with the knight
coming here but then I can always cover
on d2 and meanwhile
Kings should be able to walk in so I
won't surprising he doesn't go for it
bishop c6 that's just a nicer move but I
don't think Bishop c5 was anything wrong
but that's what a strong player does
he'll see a position like this and he
knows what his opponent wants he wants
to take make your life hard push that
pawn but he doesn't he doesn't even
consider that at first he thinks well
wait a minute
I have this to lean back on you know in
the worst case but let me see if I can
find a better move that doesn't even
give my opponent counter play he finds
bishop c6 and to be honest that kind of
makes his life a lot easier
Bishop c6 and you just win a piece so
nice game by natka he lost early on a
tough game but he's bounced back he's
bounced back and let's take a look at
Magnus here who is trying to win an
endgame this is the position he has the
bishop against the night and he has the
pawns pushing on the other side of the
board after Knight takes oh oh that's a
nice that's a nice shot I think he
simplifies that to a draw yeah I think
this one is going to be a draw here rook
F is gonna play rook there and then King
there he's gonna try to win but I don't
think he can it's a he's being tricky
though he's being tricky yeah King
before a ruinous he king there no I
thought we would see King c4 I don't
think these rook checks are very good
but it doesn't really matter at the end
of the day this is the most drawn
position I will be very surprised if
Magnus can with his position that should
never be never be happening before yeah
both players are probably gonna just
sack their ropes for the pawn and that
will be it but Magnus is gonna play it
yep I remember one player getting nine
out of nine I think I was commentating
for that one Alexander bortnik did get
nine and a nine that was one of the best
performances I've seen in
Tuesday history so there we go they're
gonna sacrifice the rooks and make a
draw so Magnus finally held to a draw in
a nice game by Petrosian I think he
found that 94 check move at the end
which really saved him there that was
that was the important move let's take a
look at Michael q2 d5 Michael Brown from
the USA and I am I believe he just got
his second GM norm if I'm not mistaken
extremely recently at the Isle of Man
tournament ironically HS comm tournament
so he's doing well he's doing launch
Escom tournaments let's see if he can
bring the same success here to title
Tuesday but he just scored a nice
grandmaster norm he had to win in the
final round against 2,700 and he did it
so that always always impresses me the
ability to win on demand like that he is
isn't he very impressive
okay they're both gonna get Queens but
there's a little trick that if you get a
queen I'll give you a check and then I
take your rook I give you check and take
your rook so are you taking on e7 if you
take on e7 and then make a queen I mean
I can just take the pawn and there's no
way that yeah that's actually pretty
tricky here yeah if you make a queen now
Queen takes a6 you shouldn't be losing
this with white okay I think he's going
to give a check and take the Queen and I
think he's calculated that it's a draw
is that right takes king there
I think he's calculated this correctly
yeah this is just gonna be a draw there
it is Knight takes pawn and a draw
against a meet Andre Kim what other
games are still going in the round
should be still quite a few Alexander
Don chenko is playing against Rexel and
even we saw before and this position
looks like it looks like one that black
should should have all the chances to
win here Bishop d5 Bishop c6 so King
over if b5 bishop see 8b 6
king d6 wow he really flipped that one I
don't think that should have happened
there alexandra duchenko just kind of
pulled it out of the Hat there but
there's no way that should have happened
why it's just winning now let's go back
to that position it looks to me like
black should be the one with chances
here but Bishop d5 Bishop d5 Bishop c6
and I think what all you had to do here
was bring the bishop let's say to d3 b5
King here b6 King Lear b7 King there and
then you can go pick off the pawn so I
mean that's just a big big miss played
by black now it's just over
there it is white wins but a big choke
by black there that endgame with the
pawns in the dark squares normally only
black should be able to win those
positions so he definitely miss played
that one
Gawain Jones executing or being no he is
playing black here he's actually losing
the Queen against rook endgame ooh miss
play thereby by white who kind of messed
up the technique by the looks of it and
can black actually draw this one rook f3
no he's checking Wow white really messed
up the technique there what happened oh
he got this position that's extremely
surprising to get this position and not
be able to win here is this problem
you're supposed to check here and then
check here right and now you have a
checkmate threat which is why the King
can't go this way so when the King goes
this way you have a check here check
here threatening mate if you go that way
and remember if you ever block with the
rook there's also mate and then when the
King goes here then you give a check
there and you take the rope that's how
you win this endgame I think I gave this
lecture last time I was watching a title
Tuesday it's a very simple procedure but
what he did in the game we can actually
go back what he did in the game was he
played Queen e5 Oh draw by stalemate oh
my god but okay there's so many things
to talk about that is just the worst
play with the Queen and rook I've ever
seen so what did he do in the game he
did Queen g7 and the issue is that I can
play King f1 because there's no Queen a1
checkmate
so and then of course let's see what
happens
now this is king h3 and he actually
misses it he plays rook h2 but then
thankfully white allows it again route
g3 that is so bad the technique guys
these are basic basic end games these
are basic engines it's like the bishop
and Knight checkmate it might seem
overwhelming at first but once you learn
the pattern it really is very very
simple now this is not good to see from
our title players in this tournament
there's always some end games that
really make you cringe when you when you
look at them but that is I mean we're on
to the next round we got it we got to
move on from that one I can't I can't
keep thinking about that here we go
Magnus Carlsen against Alexander
moskalenko now I don't know what it is
with this guy he's always 2700 blitz
he's an I am I don't really know much
about him at all really he always does
well in title Tuesday's so I don't I
don't know how he keeps doing so well he
needs to okay he used to get his GM
title updated or something a title
player ill title player I mean that's
what title Tuesdays for it's a
collection of apparently the strongest
title players and then what we always
see is basic end games that they just
they just fail on the spot all the time
and I've failed them as well so it's
it's the pressure of the the time
control the tournament everything it's
just hard to handle
we have forget our basic things but the
only thing that I've never made a
mistake on is something like that where
I dunno how to do it if I know the
technique in an end game that's
something I just won't forget but
missing basic tactics know they're there
I'm a specialist but I'm happy to say
I've never really messed up and then
game technique where it really is
technically winning
95 takes we're gonna see Queen Age 5
and take that but it's black really
unhappy with that oh hang on a sec hang
on sorry I didn't realize the bishop was
hanging what was black doing there then
night o night Knight to a4 was played I
thought this was just a basic tactic to
pick up the piece but of course the
bishops hanging you're gonna take that
and Magnus is going on the offensive
here with maybe Bishop b2 rook c1 maybe
bring the rook up to the third rank yeah
something like this looks really
dangerous but he's going for f6 and e5
magnets not gonna allow that you're
definitely not gonna see him exchange
the Queen's here he's keeping the
Queen's on the board
I think White's actually yeah White's
down a pawn here white is down upon but
all his pieces seem to very nicely
placed here Queen there now what's the
idea with that after rook e1 rook e8
he's going for the rook lift is it
Knight f5 then he's gonna play him this
is the concern is what do you do about
this bishop
he's a very very bad piece Magnus going
for the pawn sack going for the
compensation nice to see him playing so
loose he he's feeling good Queen f2
stopping at age 485 allows the bishop to
go to a6 but I don't think it has time
to go there
meanwhile White's planning it was like
g4 King age 2 and maybe f5 g4 f5 coming
soon to a theater near you probably king
h2 there it is yeah this is just that
the patient waiting move that you'll see
from strong players we might see one of
these rook moves g4 can also be
considered but I think his pressure is
gonna be on the e6 pawn and playing
something like g4 and f5 in the very
near future
Bishop a6 here is that an option looks
like rookie 6 is possible yeah Bishop a6
just rookie 6 but if we can't develop
the bishop we have to believe maybe rook
a7 and
87 something like that g4 here what do
we think about g4 very risky opens the
entire King I don't think Magus wants to
play that risky just yet I feel that he
probably believes he can improve his
position with the pieces before before
committing to something that ruins the
pawn structure quite permanently Bishop
c3 and yeah again it's just back to this
bishop I don't know how to develop it
and rook a 7 there's always a Knight
takes c6 shot with the rook hanging so
he's resorting to moves like Knight to
b7 and f5
ooh this is nasty
this position and you just can't move
anything that's the problem for for
moskalenko here
you can't move hardly any of your pieces
rook a 6 didn't lose the rook rook a 6
would have hung the rook so that
wouldn't have been a very good move and
rook a 7 was walking into the Queen on
that diagonal but this is also
completely over here so Magnus I mean
he's just dusting people he's not having
an issue at all here Bishop d2 Queen h5
g 4 and what the Queen has to go back to
h8 or something it's just terrible
terrible
so probably start by taking this with
check maybe take you with check and
maybe in something like 97 what does he
want to do take with the rook no Queen
b6 yeah Magnus has only used a minute
right now
I mean he's up on time he's just up on
everything rookie 7 then we can take
this with the rook that will be winning
now he's probably gonna take this
the alternative is checked but then
there's rookie 7
now if you take this and plate Queen c6
and take that that was probably blacks
idea of the queen F to move at the end
and then ow okay he just wins the rook
the I can't even keep up with what
Magnus is doing he's already got it all
planned out but let's take a look at
what exactly brought that up because I
think is a really instructive sacrifice
he happily gives away this C pawn here
because he knows the power of this
Knight on c5 it's restricting the entire
position now maybe in this case black
had to immediately just say you know
what I have to get rid of that knight
Knight d7
I think that might have been the best
move here because that night caused a
huge problem the entire game I don't
think I don't think black ever developed
his bishop and hey he moved it once he
developed it and then it was basically a
force loss so that's it Magnus he is on
a roll right now and let's take a look
at Nakamura who is playing black just
has to convert this but he's up upon and
the exchange that should be no problem
for him
I agree funky Sharky we are watching
Magnus Carlsen be an artist right now
with what some of the Blitz games we're
seeing these are very very nice to watch
okay well let's leave NACA to take care
of his his business here technique will
be needed let's take a look at Akshat
chandra who started the day with a much
higher blitz rating i think he was very
close to 2800 if i recall are we gonna
see f4 check that's usually the response
when you see move like h4 a common idea
is to do this to get the pawn over there
to the h-file and sort of isolate these
these pawns here the other idea of
course is just simply playing h6 so I
wonder which one will see f4 there it is
very nice
take this pawn very common idea you
distract the King and actually how do
you stop this now has to be Knight there
or Knight to f3 actually Knight f3 could
have been played as well
black in advance this pawn can advance
this pawn but I think White's gonna run
out of moves here
a5 looks like a very good move that
pawns on a light square now you can even
just go take it but no this Knight is
trapped I would play the move h5 I love
the move h5 I don't want to allow Knight
to g4 there we go beautiful move and
just take this pawn and when you move
the knight just take it no matter where
it goes very easy nice technique King
III move what a nasty move - ok that's
it that is it
Chandler goes down here but that's a
very very nice game let's take a look
here
let's take a look here you can hear him
yeah he is coming he says I can hear the
incoherent yelling exactly Michael open
you know something's happening as he's
definitely going for he's going for this
and all the pawns seem to fall here Erik
with 3 points right now so he's got a
big big comeback to make and this looks
like one of the first steps in doing
that this pawn is just hanging with
check so I think this this game is just
over he resigns there you go
chess brawl coming back into the
tournament he's got 4 points now after
this round we will update you on the
standings remember it's 10 rounds and
we're going into round 7 next so still
games to go here we have Segura of from
Russia and it looks like he's losing
here black I think
Tarlov Clemson's in Tarlov should be
winning this position with black yeah
King h7 must be yeah there you go
King h7 and you've just got too many
pawns here so do you take this yeah it
takes but it's check so King g7 you have
to be a bit careful of this pawn
sometimes Queen takes b5
that's check I wonder if this position
is winning I have a feeling
that it should be okay so I think he's
just gonna start walking his King up and
hopefully find a way to hide it
King f6 King f5 yeah I think you just
walk up the board here and there should
be a place to hide the King in the
position here
yeah the King just keeps going up the
board okay now now we have to be here
and then here Queen b1 King d2 and then
if check again we have the pawn push so
Queen before might be the only move
there it is
now how should black execute this he
wants to free up this pawn this move is
so that he could play King there now
King d1 looks like a great move Queen b3
check and be played there's no C - I'm
not sure about this one now C - he's
putting the King over here in the corner
because he doesn't want the King to be
over here where it can run into some
checks but he missed that one yeah and
now you just queen so Segura goes down
here he didn't quite get his King all
the way to the corner he didn't quite
get it there but you although it looks
funny it is part of the technique in
these Queen and pawn and games is you
don't want your king close to the pawn
it runs into checks you get forked and
then your opponent just has the extra
pawn so you want to put it as far away
as you can from the pawn that's that's
why he was trying to run to the corner
there but he didn't quite get there in
time he got caught he got tripped up the
shoestring tackle I think that's the end
of the round so let me update you guys
with the standings look at that
Toby Wan Kenobi I think he's gonna play
Magnus now right guys because this was
the this was the match of the first one
Toby Wan kenobe now has six out of six
that's incredible we're finally gonna
have to pay attention to his games blitz
stream looks like he lost in the last
round he did drop a game but 5 5 out of
6 for blitz stream is is a very good
very good score for him karo 5 out of 6
he's still coming back
let's take a look will it be the rematch
yes it's magnus carlsen against obi-wan
Kenobi let's take a look there we go
kobe-wan kenobi magnus carlsen
maintaining is 3035 blitz rating and i
think this one was indeed this was where
the physician stopped last time so told
me one kenobi did have some time to
check the position and get ready for
Magnus and it will be a Queen's Indian
this time and here we are in the live
position after 94 a few exchanges here
now obviously White's happy to exchange
against Magnus but in terms of the chess
position
I think Magnus is actually the one who's
happier to exchange here black normally
I mean in the Queen's Indian you can't
complain with controlling the e4 square
getting all these trades I mean you just
have everything you want he's gonna play
h6 and g5 so I think white is is
probably just gonna play 92 or 91 and
just try to keep trading pieces but that
is at the end of the day what Magnus
wants that is what he wants I know it
looks good that you're happy to trade
pieces with a real champion you know try
to try to make a draw but for the
position it seems like it caters more
towards towards black so Knight h4
tricky move Queen f7 with this idea
obviously and if you don't take back d5
comes and this pawn starts to stay there
and g5 so nice move by Magnus and again
you just have control over batter
squares than white now there's there's
nothing wrong really with White's
position but you're trying to make it
even trying to trade pieces but you have
taken a few weaknesses that you didn't
have - so there's g5 coming up soon in
the position you can put the knight in
on e4 probably Kings should go to h7 and
we might see some very explosive move
like if the knight moves you might see
II five really could see some
explosiveness in the position c5
now 95 Queen d2 doesn't lose a pawn 94
or whites gonna move the knight to
defend the pawn on g3 but then I think
you just lose your see pawn over there
so what's going on here Knight age 4 I
guess that was forced but I don't like
that and I don't H for at all it's
running into g5 now yeah he has to come
back because of g5 we might see Magnus
switch yeah he has switched the pieces
over to that operative diagonal he's
gonna put the Queen on d5 Brooklyn c8
maybe bring the king in a good end game
for Magnus is is possible from this
position maybe rook c8 here Knight f6
what's he up to
so you want to put the knight on d5
that's what it looks like Brooke c2 so
now the knight can even swing to to be 4
in some cases like night before in
Queenie for rook c1 and Magnus wants the
knight back there I think this is gonna
be an endgame that's the best Magnus can
do but don't get me wrong black is
better here this is a bad structure for
white to have you you have these two
pawns here which means the e4 square
belongs to black king f7 like we
expected is this a live game or
pre-recorded you shouldn't even have to
ask
this is a live game this is title
Tuesday for November King g1 and what's
gonna happen rook tasty - after rook
takes c2 we might just see Brooke c8
yeah simple as that
and if Queen c1 I'm assuming he's very
comfortable with taking and playing
ninety five and playing that endgame
there's still a lot to prove for white
black plays b5 before maybe Knight c3
okay I think the end game is is really
good for black a car lost the game in
round two sir 20 or Sarah 20 if you're
Spanish but he lost in round 2 so he's
still on his comeback
Queen d2 probably before those ideas
like Queen c3 bringing the knight in
black has a very very nice endgame
position here this pawn on d6 is the
operative pawn in the position that
pawns on d5 of course we lose all the
squares that we have covered but now 93
just doesn't do anything you're
attacking this pawn here now the Queen
comes into c2 even c3 because if you
take then you lose the a to pawn I think
white is in serious trouble here that's
already a pawn so oops that's not a move
that's already upon so 91 could even be
considered there but then maybe there's
a knight takes g3 so yes he is gonna
give it up he's gonna lose that pond I
imagine he's just gonna play d5 here
yeah he's gonna go for it but this pawn
covers the knight entrances so I think
the black King can just hide on on h7
and yeah I don't see I don't see
anything here e 2 is hanging which is
why
Magnus is confidently playing d4 like
that Queen f3 has to be played Knight
there looks possible
I think night there could be played but
then King f2 he's gonna take that for
sure and his is Magnus running what's
going on here oh yeah I guess he still
can't take the pawn so he's gonna do it
that way yeah this works the knight
can't really enter the position and this
pawn is being attacked so can we defend
the pawn with a move like King f3 that
would be my first question but then
probably Queen d2 and Queen e3 so it's
gonna be night f2 and after Queen takes
there's obviously this check and at
least a mate in one and if you take
their take back there's no check or even
just finesse Queen d5 really nice stuff
bye-bye Magnus and this Queen just
doesn't have a single check on the board
Queen d5 guys that's not even style
points that is just yeah that is an
extremely
and I don't think I don't think White
has anything here Toby looks like he's
going down there's a check but okay no
matter where the king goes I think
Magnus is just running running away with
this one is he gonna put it back on h7
or is he gonna play King age five Magnus
has no fear I mean if you calculate of
course there's nothing wrong with it but
man it looks scary putting your king
there Oh Magnus played Queen III because
he has an extra pawn over there so that
was a good way of simplifying the
position but King age five look at that
Magnus is just in cruise control like
that he doesn't feel like he's in any
danger in any of these positions he's
getting the positions he wants the end
games he wants he's grinding and he
doesn't feel like at any point there's
worry about an upset and that's a very
nice position to be in as as the top
seed he's just sort of taking care of
business
in in a nice way we want to see things
like naca carlson and we're gonna need
naka to to keep pace with them not guys
to keep winning if we want to see that
match up and that could just literally
decide first place when we see that
Bishop h5 now no matter where this name
goes I've seen NACA actually do this
before use those two bishops but Renato
Terry Lujan I mean he's just taking that
we've seen Aggies of two bishops before
but is it gonna be just king d6 now no
bishops coming back here only black can
win this position Bishop d6 only black
can win the Knights attacking c4 I don't
see I don't see any way that is he gonna
take that and go for the the draw it
might even still be losing I think it
might be losing Renato Terry Lujan
declined to draw we will see I think
it's probably winning for black but it's
tough all they agreed to a draw is that
really is that really just a draw
I thought there was at least some some
tries there okay I would have played it
on at least I mean you have an extra
pawn that's given too much respect
giving too much respect in my opinion
got to play that one on least make him
show you the draw maybe it is a draw but
you got a you got a display the
technique that was a game actually for
first place but with naka drawing and
having lost earlier I think he's a full
point behind Magnus now and there's only
three more games after this there's only
three more games so it's getting tougher
and tougher to actually catch up let's
take a look at this game which with the
rook on 88 it actually makes me think
only black has the winning chances but
that is of course gonna be a draw it is
gonna be a draw by repetition as neither
person can make progress king h2 rook
check so that game is a draw as the
games in round seven are winding down
let's take a look at a few of the other
ones we have Maxime Lugovoy Lugovoy and
this guy I saw at the Riga Technical
University open look at his rating
he's 2019 and I'll tell you his rating
is feed a rating was about twenty four
seventy and I think he performed almost
2700 in the tournament that I saw so I
don't know what this guy's deal is but
he's a grossly underrated player it
seems in in almost every format and yeah
you just take on take the gum he's got
two Queens and he he he wins what looks
like a crushing fashion here so I don't
know what this guy's deal is but he
seems to be he seems to be very talented
and very underrated I was looking at his
his feed a graph a while ago so
interesting player he's only 2000 and
he's a GM it's gotta be the lowest blitz
rating on on chess calm for a GM maybe
let's take a look at weather probably
the last games in the round
there we go it's night against rook any
predictions a shot Chandra with the rook
Charles a pata with the night this is
usually a very easy one to draw we'll
see if he's able to do it
94 ok 3 yeah king d4 I guess and usually
you can push the king of the side of the
board with some effort but you can't go
can't do better than that
maybe rookie 3 check King III 94 of
course
I would play rogue c3 here live King d1
King III probably rookie 7 check and if
King there think the knight feels a
little weird so Brooke goes over and you
can probably force the King to the edge
but then the hard part then the hard
part
kingi - we're back here so I think is
probably gonna be a draw although he can
force the King to the side of the board
I think if he if he actually wants to
now King D 3 and King Defour and he just
escapes again nothing going on here and
I believe this is the last game in the
round so we'll just stay with it but it
should be a draw and then we'll be
moving into round 8 out of 10 so only
three more games left in this tournament
the title Tuesday for November edition
we got the sirens outside the sirens
guys there they are coming to take away
Akshay Chandra for not being able to win
this end game this is blasphemy
rook against Knight dead drawn but he's
but he's trying to win it he's trying to
win it and the side the side you can
hear the sirens they're coming to take
him away rope to d5 no no no way to do
it I shot it's got to be 50 moves by now
someone's got to claim a draw somebody
click the draw button
does I think I've counted 50 moves since
we've been here guys somebody clicked
draw there we go all right we're on to
round 8 yeah that's what I'm talking
about
basics I don't really understand the guy
has a really interesting feed a profile
Maxine loo golf squirt yeah pretty
interesting I don't know he's really low
rated his losses are extremely peculiar
and he seems to be quite talented
so Magnus let's just show the standings
six and a half out of seven clear first
blitz stream might get Magnus in this
game probably does let's take a look
but he's six out of seven Toby Wan
kenobe after just losing six out of
seven
we have celebs LA Arabic Falcon chasing
six out of seven Dimitri on Drake in six
out of seven and there is Hikaru
five-and-a-half so he has got some work
to do three more games guys these are
all must wins for anybody who wants to
share first place because Magnus is 1/2
point ahead of the competition and it
looks like oh he didn't get paired
against blitz stream that would have
been a fun one instead he got celebs
Saleh this is gonna be a very big match
and yes again we see the D for Bishop f4
Knight c3 system being used by Magnus
here and in this one when black plays 97
and takes you take with the bishop and
then the issue is you're threatening
Bishop takes and g4 and if the knight
moves you take the bishop on g7 and play
g4 Magnus has done g4 anyway that's the
idea this opening you got a very very
quick attack so he could decide on long
castle here I'm sorry he couldn't decide
alone Castle he could set on f3 here he
could also take this or he could play g5
I'm not sure what he's gonna do probably
f3 and there he goes
f3 white wants the long castle bring a
rope to g1 and this could be a very fun
attacking game
I think the London system is boring take
a look at this Magnus attacking the
kingside after only ten moves like I was
saying if takes takes the ideas Bishop
f6 there's long castle and what do you
do about Magnus just bringing the rook
to the G file I mean such a caveman
attack but when the world champion
doesn't she gotta respect it
this is the instrumental piece here that
guy is taking back on h5 if he is not
there to do that black is getting mated
on the G file whoa that is surprising
why did he do that I wonder if pawn
takes does he wanna play 94 and go for
simplifications I don't get it I don't
think that's a good move I don't think
that's right at all so if I take what's
he up to
is he gonna take take and then 97 that
might make more sense but still this
looks good for white I got age 5 and
coming it's gotta be 97 here you could
try 94 but that looks risky yeah 97 so I
I mean you could keep the bishop but I
don't see an issue with taking and maybe
e4 before looks good if h5 maybe g5 so
he wants to g5 and then aged 5 so he
wants all the breaks he wants g5 to stop
black from controlling these squares and
then he wants h5 and e4 he's gonna get
all the breaks here in the position and
blacks just getting attacked this is
nice this looks very nice how do you not
take on d5 right now he takes on d4 is
that the idea queen f2 so if takes takes
then e 5 of course drops the pawn and if
the King moves the pawn is hanging
anyway so what's black didn't do if he
takes money for take with a knight
takes their and then II five yeah but
White has a good structure here widest
has a good structure
I think White's gonna be happy you know
maybe move like C three maybe a three
King be one just move the pieces over
you always have this in reserve so black
kinda has to keep it rook there and
maybe you can switch this rook to the F
file and start to put some serious
pressure on f7 so maybe King D one here
to start kind of like the idea of king
b1 just sheltering the king and he has
done it get the King off the C file no
need to rush black rook has to stay here
by the looks of it otherwise h5 is quite
strong and meanwhile white can take his
time with moves like a3 c3 rook here to
cover the second rank and get the rook
on the F file the opening was d4 Knight
f6 Bishop f4 London system by Magnus
black chose to fianchetto Magnus went
for an early night C 3 and here we are
that's an opening he's repeated time and
time again so not really a surprise
there we can see some tactics boiling
here there are some there are some ideas
something with a brook f7 takes in a 96
check and a queen c4 the patterns are
starting to emerge guys this is looking
pretty nice for white so he's attacking
the knight rook e1 is probably gonna be
met by Knight c5 rookie one night c5
Knight f6 made a four type of thing
he's a 95 happening must be the move
must be the move cuz otherwise white is
playing one of these moves and kicking
pieces out rook c6 no something doesn't
feel correct about that a3 yeah a3 looks
good and now aged 5 with the Queen
supporting it black is gonna have a real
tough time defending it White's up on
time almost double in fact double the
time here that black has Arabic Falcon
he has six points he's chasing but rate
Oh if he can't even take that pawn it
must just be h6 just age 6
rook f1 must be crushing here yeah
that's got to be good enough
rook f1 guys I don't even know how to
survive here because all the end games
are bad
there's Queen takes d7 right now there's
a night coming f6 move this does not
look pretty he wants rook takes d7 he's
stubborn he wants that trick nasty nasty
completely out playing his opponent from
start to finish
Magnus looks very good there was even
Knight take c7 in that position and they
takes g6 but Magnus doesn't need it he
goes for Queen there and now he wins in
a full rook actually so it's just over
completely dominated his opponent Wow
Wow guys Magnus is running away with
this tournament that was only two games
left and Nakamura let's get a look at
his game he's playing black and he is
dead lost against Toby Toby Wan kenobe
King III what is this just ruck takes B
seven why not King III why not
ya King III and that cos scrambling here
but no there's there's nothing to be
done you can just take pawn after pawn
Wow Nakamura he's down like four pawns
here and the exchange so I don't think
he's coming back in this tournament to
catch ya just rook takes Knight yes he
will not even taking the last pawn there
King III let's go you're up way too many
pawns black should not even have a
chance in the same game
rook a five yeah no this is done
Wow so Magnus showing his consistency
whereas naka isn't gonna be making the
comeback I'd be surprised I don't think
we're gonna see naka Magnus in his
tournament guys I really don't think so
there's just no way anymore because
Magnus keeps winning and akaru is not
following the same he's not following
the same path if he doesn't win and
match
Magnus is stamina then you know Magnus
is just setting a better pace I don't
think we're gonna see it there's a
checkmate naca goes down to Toby Wan
kenobe a huge upset 2509 taking down the
3k karu wow that's a big result we are
not gonna see
naca against Carlsen this tournament and
the standings are getting completely
shaken up by these results h4 look at
this wild position well unfortunately
Queen h7 is a it's a pretty tough move
to face rook there g3 and then what no
rook g5 is the move man this is a crazy
position you gotta feel that black is
winning this f3 no he goes for h2 King
g3 oh I don't like exposing the light
squares like that no I hate I hate that
that does not feel right normally you
never want to do this look at whites
control now of this diagonal that does
not feel correct you can now bring the
rook out and around or something like
that I don't think that's good
there's also Queen h3 as he's pointed
out by playing that move Queen h7 King
there what's he planning though I think
you just have to bring the Queen back I
don't see what blacks threat is just
Queen d3 let's say or even yeah just a 5
just get the pawn going
five that was a bit of a sloppy move
there this did not have to happen King
back I think you could maybe play move
like rook F one with a queen on e5 rook
F one is that possible I think they
might go for repetition here but I
thought white had the position in his
pocket earlier but man this this looks
like it might be a repetition here these
guys look ready to take a draw I'm not
sure about rook f1 though it looks
interesting
no I think I think this is a draw either
one can claim a draw here I'm pretty
sure that's been three times yeah okay
someone press draw save as the suspense
oh he plays on bishop f1 Wow Bishop d3
King g7 Queen there Rho keV seven I
don't I mean what is white thinking here
can you really escape this wait wait
wait
King g8 o kicking on away King g8 not
maybe King Jays possible but I guess I
guess what yeah actually what do you
play on King g8 because if you go here
for the mate it looks like I can just
make a queen with check most importantly
and then that's mate in one and if you
check oops
if you check me here what's happening
here ooh maybe Bishop c4 Bishop c4 Queen
takes Queen g6 rook h2 these are some
these are some serious lines and I have
King g7 check and we win the rook I can
even consider king g6 here anyway it's
all wild these guys agree into a draw
better safe than sorry but that position
looked like it had a lot of stuff still
still in the position okay well we're on
to round 9
magnus carlsen is playing blitz stream
who refuses to lose look at him
seven points out of eight he is second
place behind magnus carlsen and he has
the audacity to play g4 move one guys if
we see a victory for white here this is
just going to be legendary one and
opening the Grob against the world
champion why not that lone pawn on g5
disturbing the Knights from coming to f6
white wants to launch a quick attack
we're probably gonna see black
counter-attack with quick play in the
center but there you go
the Grob against the world champion you
gotta love it you gotta love it
somewhere out there decline is smiling
a3 what's it gonna be does does black
just go like with c5 trying to decide
how important it is to just open the
center completely c5 doesn't look insane
to me in this position because don't we
want to just blast open the position if
we take this pawn we take this one type
of thing that looks like a pretty
interesting option but he's gone to
defend the pawn just bring the bishop
out remember if knight c7 there's c5
he's going for c5 anyway I think he's
playing Bishop f4 next is that right
Knight f4 yeah the black just opens the
position with b6 and White's position
does not look good but remember blood
stream just a national master it's got
the seven points out of eight in the
title Tuesday he's up against GM Magnus
Carlsen who might sack a piece right
here with pawn takes c5 and pawn takes
d4 dad is looking very appetizing but no
he keeps it with Queen c8 all right all
right I thought we were gonna really
have some fun there the knight own a6 is
not impressing me
definitely not impressing me he's got to
undermine this Center does Magnus
otherwise I don't see I don't see how it
works with Queen takes c6 there's a nice
tactic
a 528 screen and you take and of course
it's with a check so white took the
bishop on e6 then played e3 but no
usually this stuff fails to stuff on the
f5 however like I was saying that night
I don't need six guys it does not
impress me honestly speaking I think
this is like maybe one of the worst
positions Magnus has had I want to be
harsh here but there was Bishop f1 which
is a massive threat the Knight has to go
back to b8 you just have to make sure
you do not fall for this tactic Bishop
a5 just don't fall for that as long as
you don't play that I think White has a
great position
guys - Carlsen I think he's actually in
trouble here at the very least it's fair
to say that I think it's one of his
worst positions today I think we can we
can all agree the rook move is to save
the night that's that's why he did that
yeah and ib8
probably something like a5 next but now
if 97 there's no Bishop a5 tactic so
that's just hanging pawn so I do not
like blacks position at all here yeah a5
is gonna be played White's gotta move a
little bit faster he's got a good
position and this is from the Grob guys
all hail the grub the master race
opening what do you play is white here
it's hard to keep rolling the pawns
meanwhile look at the time it's almost a
minute advantage blitz dream I believe
blitz dream is streaming this right now
yes literally so King demon king c2 I
like it I actually like that King is
very safe on c2 I think that's a good
idea
he's just gotta play faster he's down
one full minute here converting against
a strong player is completely another
thing I agree and E 5 is coming here
comes the counter-attack to counter play
92 but this is gonna get taken I think
yeah it's got to be taken right will
Queen a6 yeah this is where you
the bishop f1 move but 92 Magnus picks
his moment must be Queen d3 here right
this should work I think Queen d3 King
c1 I guess you want to be careful
trapping your Queen something like this
Knight takes you definitely have to be
careful of that yeah so he actually goes
back with the knight and Wow
Bishop f1 it might have arrived just in
time now there might be a knight move
somewhere black suddenly Shahrukh takes
F to the knight can move anywhere and
then the Queen's gonna go back to c8 but
then you gotta deal with rook takes f2
and with 30 seconds on the clock
what is gonna happen Knight f4 so Queen
c8 yeah covering ninety-six Bishop h3
and it's gotta be what Knight back to f5
no okay he's gonna go for it
rook takes f2 yeah takes probably the
bishop comes to e6 Bishop e6 this is
hanging that's hanging then there's this
guy there's also Bishop e6 to look out
for this is a wild position I like
white's chances it's just that time
because remember if white gets the rook
to f1 and plays Bishop e6 there's all
sorts of back ranked tactics this stuff
can really work frog we're seeing Magnus
Carlsen getting his biggest test against
the national master blitz dream who we
all know and love on the online
interface he streams his games he's
streaming right now as far as I know
against Magnus Carlsen
imagine if he streams his victory that
would make him go crazy Bishop e6 is in
the position rook f1 as well that's a
hanging night I mean Magnus is in a
tough position he's hanging full knights
and whites not even taking them I like
to move rook f1 we got Bishop e6 what's
going on here guys the reason that I'm
guessing he might not be streaming this
is cuz he's playing so well and when I
stream I play awful there's no way I
could play this well when I'm stringing
rook a seven okay it's gotta be
basics right and then Queen b6 Magnus is
actually probably completely losing this
if I'm honest here so what about Queen
b6 takes that's a bit surprising seems a
bit slow honestly but maybe it works
she's only got six seconds though six
seconds so what he wants this and rook
f7 and takes so Magnus is gonna go for
d4 Knight d5 and what happens after this
oh sorry of course there's night before
now night before he now now Magnus is
covering 96 yes 96 okay he just lost his
queen that's not a good oh excuse me he
didn't lose his queen but night before
and then rook takes b2 very close to
losing the Queen Queen f7 is a huge
threat
oh man with five seconds left he is
barely hanging in there it's Magnus
gonna sack what's going on here actually
Queen f7 is unstoppable I think he might
have the win here wait wait I think he
has the win here Queen f7 is easy to
calculate oh my goodness he's got to
take that but the knight back to d5 okay
white white has this position but with
four seconds can you finish it off
Queen b8 okay there's no checks though
black can move the Queen in somewhere
Queen b5 Queen before there it is Queen
before are we gonna see e7 two seconds
Queen d6 threatening mate the rooks not
hanging but there is 93 in some
positions this might be a draw oh my
goodness what's going on here King to c1
you lose a pawn with check remember you
can't take that bishop because of
checkmate on FA but if black can ever
get his knights involved with a check
there will be a maid coming but I'm not
sure that he can King b2 know this might
be a draw by repetition incredibly first
of all can black defend Magnus offer to
draw and the game is drawn that is
Wow what were we looking at there this
game went completely wild 95 and Queen
d6 everything was protected the best
black can do is a draw there's no way to
play on with maid on the board geez
Magnus survives the worst there that was
his biggest scare the entire tournament
and what he knows with the Grob who died
was intense guys the world champion
survives with a draw and he's still in a
great position to win this tournament
with only one game remaining he's gonna
get the white pieces in the last round
as Toby again upsets Vladimirovich Wow
he beat on Dracon as well as Nakamura in
the same tournament I mean that's he's
got a resume right there you can already
put that on your resume that's that's
enough Toby one can all be beating
Nakamura and beating Dimitri on Dracon
in the same blitz event that's pretty
insane those are two of the world's best
basically black one in this game so that
is the end of the round let me bring up
the standings for you there you go
Toby Wan kenobe look at these tied for
first eight out of nine I mean what what
is this he lost a Magnus in fairly
convincing fashion and then he beats on
Drake and he beats Nakamura he's eight
out of nine tied with Magnus Carlsen
better on tiebreaks is he gonna finish
ahead of him because remember guys
they've already played so they're not
playing each other this round blitz
stream and Terry Renato Luhan tied for
second place but look at that it's an IM
in first and nm and third and I am in
fourth I mean this is not the tournament
for the GMs there are upsets everywhere
what can we expect in this last round
well let's just get right into it take
those standings off your screen so we
got Magnus Carlsen against Terry Renato
Luke hunt
Magnus playing with the black pieces
going for the Queen's Indian and before
we get into the game I'm also going to
be following the other game of the round
which is going to be
blitz dream who's also in first place
he's playing Arabic Falcon he's playing
black here and these are the two games
that are gonna be you know deciding the
the first place the other one being who
I'm gonna bring up on your screen right
now where is Toby there is Toby Wan
Kenobi this guy playing the white pieces
having the tournament of his life I'm
willing to say these are the games we
have to watch playing for first place so
let's get back to Magnus here as Toby
against wonderful time got blitz stream
playing against celebs LA Arabic Falcon
and GM Magnus Carlsen here with the
black pieces playing against
international master Renato Terry Luhan
from Peru
so Bishop h3 for those that don't know
the idea is to move the knight to one of
these squares so you can attack the
bishop and then when the bishop moves
white wants to play F 3 E 4 and bring
the bishop back to G 2 by the way white
offer to draw here do we think Magnus is
gonna take the draw will Magnus take
this draw by the way if Bishop c6
there's sometimes an idea of d5 in this
case it might not work because of a3 but
the idea of being something like this if
Knight takes this Bishop takes and if
Bishop takes there's something like this
but the movie a3 I think can be inserted
in that position and might be able to
save save the tactics but white offer to
draw here this Magnus gonna take it he's
still thinking about it guys cuz you
might not have a good position and he's
down a minute on the clock like more
than a minute he doesn't take it bishop
g6 he says hell no he says no bishop
back to g2 that's the idea of this
bishop h3 move kick the bishop out bring
the bishop back there it is executed and
after pawn takes white would be very
happy taking control the AFL's we have
to play a 3e
and what are we gonna see here white
probably can win this palm whenever he
wants to but I think that Magnus is
saying you know what go ahead and win
the pawn I'm going for stuff on the
Kings side Magnus is going for the win
there it is he's going for the pawn
Magnus is going for the attack there's
no way you can save this pawn as far as
I can see so he for he wants to cut the
bishop off from defense wants to play
moves like 98 and Queen h3 and h4
there you have it that's his plan that's
his plan Magnus he's got to win here
because he has some competition and Toby
Wan Kenobi
Toby Wan Kenobi by the way lost his game
if I'm reading this correctly so Magnus
actually with a win wins the tournament
outright but Toby Wan Kenobi I lost his
game already I believed a wonderful time
I didn't even get a chance to see that
game but it looked completely normal
when I saw it last so yeah I don't know
what happened there but he only has
eight out of ten so Magnus with the win
he takes this entire tournament he takes
this entire tournament right now with a
win Bishop a4 but guys what is this you
can't do that against the world champion
Queen h3 hello Knight g4 how are you not
playing Queen h3 and a heartbeat here
what are we calculated rook da wait wait
a minute what was wrong with that I want
to play Queen h3 what did I miss why
didn't we just throw in Queen h3 and
then rub d8 let's say I'm very surprised
no Queen h3 there
yeah I actually can't explain that guys
for for the first time like at least
play Queen h3 and then play rook t8 or
whatever you were gonna play that's a
little surprising
it seems that Magnus what he wants to do
is he wants to win the bishop he doesn't
need to play this kind of chess when he
can just play something like that I
guess that's what he's what are you
saying here so maybe Magnus just
switched the game plan he said you know
what I don't need to attack or go for
checkmate I can just try to win that
fish money for it which is very
peculiarly placed I don't know what's
going on with that Bishop there Queen b7
yeah he wants b5 that bishop could just
be lost here d5 may be the only move in
the position yeah b5 and after I take
Knight takes I'm attacking the bishop
there and that just might be game over
that might be game over right there yeah
I don't see a way to refute that 39
seconds and counting down for Renato
Thierry Lujan and Magnus Carlsen looks
like he just takes here and takes the
win
that's a piece for black and if Magnus
wins guys there's no one who can catch
him in this tournament that'll be a 9
out of 10 he wins a piece this is cruise
control for Magnus I mean we just have
each tournament culminates with a very
nice game against a guy who's performing
very well in the tournament so far was
seven and a half points to run out Lujan
he beats him with the black pieces here
he's up a piece this is just a matter of
technique and believe me he has that
Queen age 594 that's it Wow
this is this is just gonna be game here
Magnus is gonna go for nine out of ten
an undefeated performance here in title
Tuesday and g5 I don't see how you stop
mate here take on h4 take on h4
yeah take on g3 and there's gonna be
made down
somewhere I don't see how you stop this
okay Queen Queen c5 actually stops it
but then there's h3 yeah
h3 there's gonna be a mate nonetheless
that is cute
Wow look at that what a way to end
magnus carlsen world champion comes in a
title tuesday and makes his mark very
very well played you only seem to be in
trouble against blitz stream the very
scary game he played just last round but
he held on
he made the draw in a very very tough
position and with nine out of ten points
Magnus takes first place in the title
Tuesday clear nobody can catch him with
nine out of ten undefeated performance
and to finish off we're just going to
spectate the rest of the games that
might affect some of the standings let's
take a look at our Drake in here oh
there we go speak of the devil he has
lost because the night covers the f6
square so these rook and Knight just
don't coordinate for any attack here the
standings are almost completed there's a
few more games that could still affect
things this King and pawn and game looks
completely winning for white just d4 and
d5 and that's it yeah
d4 d5 and the King can just march over
and grab the a pawn d5 takes King takes
and you just go take the a pond here
that's it but Magnus undefeated I mean
you just can't
guys like Nakamura we're chasing him but
a draw here or lost there and you're not
gonna catch up to Magnus with the pace
that he was setting g5 so I guess do you
play h3 here
I'll be just h3 or h4 yeah taketake h5
king a7 king c7 a6 and white wins yeah
that will be it
White's gonna take the victory here
there it is okay white wins that game
let's take a look at real boy with six
and a half points also doing well this
is a battle of the IMS here this game
might be one of the last ones to finish
and then after this we can finally
announce the official final standings
but right now I can say it looks like of
course Magnus Carlsen clear first place
Toby Wan kenobe looks like he's gonna
take second place here with eight out of
ten but he's joined by a lot of people
and I don't think the remaining games
will affect the standings I think
everyone has pretty much qualified so
it's gonna be Magnus Carlsen
Toby Wan Kenobi and Genghis K taking the
top three spots but also tied with Toby
and Genghis at eight points out of ten
seems to be solemn Sal a wonderful time
Yuri solo Toby Shenko so it's a one two
three four five way tie for second but
Magnus just on top of the pack we got to
say national master blitz dream seven
and a half out of ten very very nice
performance by him that's probably his
best result in title Tuesday ever and I
think that is more than I've ever scored
entitled Tuesday that's a really good
score seven and a half out of ten got to
play against Magnus came very close to
beating him probably should have beat
him and made a draw in the end so that's
that's a great performance for him d5 I
guess yeah I think this is the last game
so we'll just wait to finish before we
can announce everything
waiting for this one to end Queen to g7
two pawns up though should always be
enough to in Queen III there we go let's
put an end to it yeah nicely done
alright so with that I think oh there's
still there's still one more game there
we go
a4 White's still trying to win this but
I think he might be I think he might be
in trouble okay I guess they'll make it
draw they'll just take all the pieces
off and that's that's gonna be a draw so
it's an a pawn so there's no winning
that position yeah y can win the pawn
and be happy that he got the extra pawn
but as long as black shuffles on the a8
and be eight squares he is never gonna
lose this position there we go I think
that this will be the end of the title
Tuesday November edition sponsored by
masterclass and let me bring up those
final standings so you guys can see
there you go well let that official
metal thing pop up on the screen first
there you go Magnus Carlsen Toby Wan
kenobe in Ganga's Kay but the official
elongated standings Magnus we can't say
enough about his performance some very
nice games with both colors and we
didn't get to see the Magnus NACA match
up we didn't get to see Magnus mvl
because not everyone completed the
tournament but it was tough
only Magnus managed to not lose or draw
against the low rated opponents so a lot
of upsets in this tournament and a lot
of I am James
Sam's performing way above their debt
ratings really made this one of the most
exciting titled Tuesday's because of all
the upsets so Toby won at the tournament
of his life eight out of ten as well
wonderful time always does well in these
tournaments and then we have Blitz
stream have to mention him seven and a
half scrolling down the list there we
have Eric Hanson seven out of ten it's a
good result but probably he dropped a
few games early in when Magnus is
setting the pace like that you you just
can't can't drop games and expect to
climb into the top ten this this
tournament was there was some big big
scores being put up as we can see here
so there you go a lot of names that we
recognize down the list this tournament
was stacked full of players 200 people
participated at the start in the end 99
players now making up a very very strong
title Tuesday for November I hope that
everyone enjoyed we had a few hiccups at
the start so today was the elongated
extended version director's cut I hope
you guys had fun we had at least 2,500
people watching the stream at some point
today so I had a lot of fun bringing you
the commentary the energy sharing the
the games with you and congratulating
Magnus on on a well-deserved victory but
thanks for sticking around for everybody
who put up with with our slow start and
I hope you enjoyed a little extra chess
and titled Tuesday's so this will be
back at the next Tuesday first Tuesday
of the next month December it's every
month guys don't miss it very strong
tournament open to any title players if
you want to follow me you can see on the
screen Adam on Hambleton on twitter and
twitch.tv slash chess bra we're on
YouTube and twitch as well if you want
to see any more of me playing chess or
doing commentary so thanks for watching
everybody I hope you guys enjoyed and I
hope to see you for the next title
Tuesday and the next chest bra shows and
hambleton's happy hour on chest comm bye
for now